welcome to the david pakman show i am
farin cousins from ring of fire with you
once again
to help close out what has been
quite a crazy week to put it mildly
so without further ado right let's just
jump right into today's story no need to
waste time let's get to it
big story happened this week the fbi
raided the homes of two individuals
involved in donald trump's fake elector
scheme those two individuals
uh brad carver who allegedly signed a
document to be a trump elector as well
as thomas lane who worked on trump's
effort to overturn the election in
arizona and new mexico
now as everybody i'm sure is aware the
doj is in fact investigating the fake
elector scheme
it's one of the few things from the
former trump administration that is
actually being investigated along with
of course the 15 boxes of documents that
were found down at mar-a-lago the doj is
also investigating that um with regard
to january 6 though
not so much we get more to that in just
a little bit but
this is a big one right we got a fake
elector we got a guy running donald
trump's you know day-to-day campaign
operations the fbi raided their homes
has seized some of their electronic
devices
and on top of that
other people also involved in the scheme
have received subpoenas
so here is what this means so far for
this investigation
it just means
that it's moving forward
i know that's a little disappointing i
know nobody ever just wants to hear that
the wheels are in motion right
we want action we we want meat we want
something of substance
that we can really sink our teeth into
and feel better
about these you know kind of slow
rolling investigations which let's be
clear that is what this is
yeah i saw a great analysis from a
writer this week that basically said
the doj is moving too slowly on this
particular story considering the fact
that this fake elector scheme didn't
just emerge on tuesday during those
hearings we've known about it for over a
year
and we're just now getting to the point
where okay well these are the fake
electors now let's go look at their
homes let's get their electronic devices
let's really start to
ramp things up a little bit i guess
whatever it is
it is too slow
but sometimes
sometimes
it's slow for a reason
other times
it's slow out of abundance of caution
and i'm afraid that that is the
situation that we are looking at right
now
the doj
led by of course attorney general
merrick garland doesn't want to give any
kind of appearance
that they are being overtly political
they want to make sure that they have
crossed their t's and dotted their eyes
before they make any moves on anyone
even some of these low level individuals
but even still
sometimes when you have the evidence you
don't need to sit on it you don't need
to wait
you don't need to hold off on issuing
subpoenas until the public is squarely
in your corner
sometimes you have to do something even
if it's unpopular if it is the right
thing to do
and i do believe that that of course is
the situation that we're looking at
right now with the fake elector scheme
i mean after all that is one of the
biggest things
obviously there is so much with january
6th and with the january 6 committee and
all of that that we could probably pop a
lot of people for a lot of different
crimes right away trump himself included
and again i'm going to get to that in
just a few moments
but
this fake elector scheme
this was the big gambit right they knew
that their court cases were losing they
knew they didn't have evidence of voter
fraud
but they pushed ahead with all of this
anyway
and in some states yeah they had people
ready to go
in michigan we found out this week that
their fake elector scheme because the
electors had to be in the state capital
uh to cast their votes so what they had
planned
which of course didn't come to fruition
but they had planned to somehow sneak
into the michigan state capitol
so that they would be present the
following day to be able to cast their
fake electoral college vote
i mean that is how deep this scheme went
i mean this truly is you know cross
country
you know north to south
south east to west all over the country
you had these little fake electors
willing to do whatever it took
to make donald trump the winner of the
election so thank goodness of course
that we do have the doj investigating
this
you know thank goodness we're seeing
some of these
positive step forward
individuals do need to be subpoenaed
they do need to you know if they're not
going to comply if we think they might
hide or destroy evidence they do have to
be rated that's how that works that's
why by the way that typically works in
that manner if you have an individual
you think could destroy evidence could
be hiding things
that's when you send the fbi in to go
try to find it
now over in georgia as well the fake
elector scheme has been gaining steam
and we have seen in recent weeks
several of the people who signed on to
be the fake electors not of course
necessarily
in a criminal way
and what i mean by that is you do have
some of the people who were the quote
fake electors in georgia
that are fully cooperating with the
investigators because they said listen
i was approached with this and they said
if these court cases
overturn everything for donald trump
we're going to need our electors are you
willing to do that and so you had plenty
of people in the state of georgia these
republicans who said oh yeah i'll do it
if if and only if
these court cases overturn the election
i'm here ready to go
and then once the court case is lost
these people said all right i'm out i'm
not going to do this
and those people have been working with
these investigators both in georgia and
the feds
and more importantly they've been giving
them names
they said listen i'm more than willing
to talk to you but i'm probably not the
guy you need you need you know this
person this person and this person the
names have not been released
so they are getting better leads and the
more leads you get
the longer the investigation takes the
more people you have to question the
more people you have to subpoena and of
course you have to go to the courts to
get the subpoenas
so maybe it's being slow rolled out of
that abundance of caution
which i do believe is the driving factor
but it also could be
that there's just so
many different leads
so many different states so many
different players
that this investigation kind of has to
go slow
because you don't want to miss anyone
and sometimes in our impatience and i'll
admit i'm probably public enemy number
one on that
sometimes we forget about that
you know we all want this kind of
instant gratification with these
investigations and unfortunately
that's just not the way it works so we
do have to be patient
we do have to let the process play
itself out because there are far too
many players here
for us to
even omit ignore or forget
a single one of them
i think this is the biggest discount
that any sponsor has ever offered on the
david pakman show this is crush organics
crush organics loves the show so much
they're giving my viewers 50 off their
entire collection of organic cbd
products when you use the code pacman
i'm the only show
where you can get this big a discount
that i like and for each sale crush
organics will donate ten dollars to the
last prisoner project that's a really
great nonprofit helps to
free non-violent drug offenders and
reform drug laws very important and it
doesn't stop there anyone who uses my
code also gets a free jar
of cbd gummies or a jar of cbd topical
cream crush has only the best organic
cbd whether you're looking for oils
creams or edibles so that's 50 off and a
free jar of gummies or topical cream and
10 bucks towards creating real change in
our justice system go to crush organics
dot u s
and use the code pacman the link is down
below